she is
so
lonely
and so that's not an excuse for her
family and this family
invites her
and she is all of a sudden accepted into
this family do you not understand that
that's the plot of dear evan hansen and
everybody hates that movie
that's the thing they didn't daddy these
guys get it right
today we're going to talk about the most
memorable holiday movie couples ever and
we're going to start with a hot one
we've got this list on looper.com and
one of the items on the list is jack and
lucy and while you were sleeping now
you're fine
i watched this movie last year for the
second time because the first time i saw
it in theaters um with my mom
and um
it's a nice movie it's a nice holiday
movie it's nice and fun and i rewatched
it last year
and i was like
this is a sweet movie and i love it i
can't wait to watch it again
i think it's great i think that the
couple in it jack and lucy played by
bill pullman and sandra bullock sandy
bully if you're cool
i think it they make a great what nina
you seem confused by what i just said
sandy bully just go on just keep talking
it's fine i just think i do think
you know is it one of the most memorable
couples in a holiday movie i mean maybe
it's a really nice holiday movie and
they they genuinely seem to fall in love
it seems it seems nice tom what were you
going to say about this movie brian you
know what i like about that couple so
much is that they
almost to the letter uh
they mirror the the relationship that i
have with my wife and that we met
while she was pretending okay thank you
my comatose brother
was her fiance
and then she lied and lied and lied for
like a month and everyone was cool with
it and then at the end of it i was like
you know who i want to do kissing with
that liar
so here's my facebook artist who worked
this movie is such a mixed bag for me
because bill pullman and sandy bully or
whatever we're calling here today right
let's make that happen um yeah they do
make a good people and jack and lucy do
have good chemistry and i like them as a
couple but the circumstances in which
they get together to call it not ideal
would be a large understatement well so
that's the complication she's a and
she's an unhinged she's a sociological
liar yeah no no no
no
let's back up here's how this movie goes
i did back up i backed up from the
ending that you liked to the beginning
impressive
election having watched this movie a
year ago
once
i recall that she has a crush on this
dude that she's never spoken to saves
him from getting run over by a train
then casually
jokingly to herself says i was gonna
marry that man someone takes it out of
context and suddenly she is swept up and
she doesn't say
no but
pretty sure she does try to say but she
but here's the thing right let us begin
at the beginning
hang on he's going hang on
she is
so
lonely
and so that's not an excuse for that
family and this family
invites her and she is all of a sudden
accepted into this family do you not
understand that that's the plot of dear
evan hansen and everybody hates that
movie
that's the thing they did that and these
guys get it right
brian read between the let's let's start
at the beginning she's a woman who looks
and behaves like a sandra bullock
character in the early 90s and she's
alone there's a reason for that we don't
get told what it is
but there is one
but if it's because her family is dead
and she doesn't know how to love how did
they die do you think brian do you think
maybe it had anything to do with the
fact that there's a woman who when
somebody goes to a hospital starts lying
all the time i have sympathy for a woman
who falls in love with peter
gallagher's beautiful sumptuous eyebrows
i have we all have who doesn't love
peter gallagher and his eyebrows you
could get lost in but you can't lie just
because of some great eyebrows
you just can't it's not okay they're
eyebrows not eyebrows
just take a moment for everybody at home
to recover from how hilarious i am
[Music]
oh god continue so anyway brian likes
liars
nina what was your choice
nina what's your choice now that we've
established that my pick is garbage
i'm gonna talk about more garbage um
so every single year i have a holiday
tradition uh with with my friends and we
have an annual watch of love actually
and when i say we have an annual watch i
mean that one year we did it without
adult beverages and it was horrible um
because i had to watch this movie with a
really clear head and it um was really
unsettling to me
um and so like yeah there's a lot of
memorable couples in love actually there
is the um
the colin firth character jamie who uh
purchases a mute woman that he cannot
communicate with
and then proposes to her with knowing
literally nothing about her they can't
speak to one another and i get that the
gist is like oh love transcends
languages like that's love actually
that's lovely
can you imagine it because like if i
remember right they they each learn like
three sentences of each other's
language right at the end so yeah but
they decide to get married anyway
because
well i'm just saying like can you
imagine if she had like if the first
thing that she had said had been like
yeah and also we need to separate the
races
like what if that had been what the
relationship turned out to be
with a racist on accident that's the
sequel divorce actually
so yeah so you've got you've got colin
firth and his and his his mute servant
that he
buys um you've got alan rickman r.i.p uh
treating beautiful perfect emma thompson
like garbage so like the hugh grant and
his like assistant storyline is pretty
endearing except for the fact that like
he uh ruins a relationship with his like
with an international ally because billy
bob thornton hits on her
and also everyone spends the whole movie
calling natalie like fat in the most
descriptive ways and i'm like she is a
normal size he's like normal beautiful
woman and everybody's like oh her thighs
are like someone who works for the prime
minister is like huge thighs i'm like
you should be fired immediately why do
you still have your job she's just
gorgeous with a normal like body not
only that but how is any of one who
works in this office like allowed to
just freely comment on a stranger's body
it's insane i have an
that's love actually
oh i just got the title uh you have like
liam neeson who's just lonely but then
he gets a claudia schiffer at the end um
for some reason
you've got the little the little dude
from game of thrones who is bad at
drumming and
um
cut that we can't
i think i think we can and we must no
i'm so sorry mr dinklage what else um no
we've got we've got jojen reed from game
of thrones and if he had been a child of
any other race he would have been
immediately tackled running through that
airport
because
white kids can get away with anything um
look i don't know oh oh and then you do
have um you have keira knightley who is
being stalked by rick grimes
and he
expresses his undying love for her by
being really mean to her all the time
and then um making out with her behind
his best friend's back great this is
great and spending 40 dollars at an
office depot he got like a bunch of
poster boys probably spent 40 pounds
which is much more expensive than 40
dollars
yeah so um
yeah
so yeah this movie is full of sociopaths
the only good character is the guy who
moves to america and immediately meets
three supermodels who are obsessed with
him and even that is weird and
problematic the only good character is
mr bean in the department you're right
you're right actually mr bean in the
whole movie he shows up multiple times
there you go is he not the department
store or another he shows up in the
airport and he helps out uh little
drummer boy as he's on his doing his run
yeah um he's like he stalls like can't
find his passport so the kid can sneak
right into security is there anything he
shows up somewhere else too he's in the
movie like a couple of times um because
he's supposed to be there's this idea
that uh he's like a christmas angel
who's like preventing people from you
know ruining their lives no i'm just
know what his name in the movie is his
name is love actually
um okay i have one final thing to say
the most memorable couple from this
movie and this is actually a positive i
will say something nice is bill nye and
his manager because if there's one
reason for this movie to exist it's bill
nye
just being profane and disgusting and
perfect and wearing the loudest shirts
anyone has ever worn
ever um and his
like dorky manager whom he loves
actually so
that's the reason for the movie to exist
anyway i look forward to this holiday
season with um
yeah a a
a nice beverage in this movie
several beverages
a bottle of beverages
so we've got some items on this list on
looper.com that i will mention because
i haven't seen all these movies i am
i haven't seen all of the christmas
movies out there but i do love a good
christmas movie we've got elf here
buddy and jovi so that's a fun little
relationship we've got the is it i mean
he appears to be like
yeah like a man trapped a boy in a man's
body with an adult woman yikes well but
that's the thing he's an innocent
fun christmas elf sure and she is a
person if the jungle had been christmas
yeah exactly tarzan if the jungle had
been christmas and also jane hated
jungles but then was convinced to love
jungles because she worked in the jungle
store yeah actually
it's a nice little parent
i can't fault elf elf is a very sweet
movie i like it quite a lot
yeah uh we've got on here john mclean
and holly
gennaro mclean and die hard is die hard
christmas movie yes moving on it's a
nice relationship in this movie because
it starts off with them just straight up
fighting with each other all the time
and there's this great moment where um
where they're trying to figure out why
the terrorists are so pissed off and
holly's just like
john's out there only john can make
someone this angry
which is definitely the kind of thing a
married person says about their spouse
sure yep yep tracks
[Laughter]
uh we've also got in here bleak outlook
of romance in this episode of whatever
our show is called we i don't think
we've
said anything good no yeah so so uh
here's one that i that i really like
actually it's from um
a movie that tom has gone on record as
saying he does not like happiest season
i love happiest season i really love
your back i don't
i know that the name of our of our of
our video here is the most memorable
holiday movie couples and i'm going to i
don't know i don't remember their names
i probably should have looked it up i'll
look it up right now one of them is
named harper harper and abby their names
are harper and abby harper is mckenzie
harper is mckenzie davis and abby is
kristen stewart boom
thank you now
that's great i think they are a great
couple even though they even though
harper lies a lot
well but that's the whole point of the
movie which is that she has she's having
a hard time coming to grips with who she
is
now and admitting to herself like and
admitting to the world like
like her actual life she's keeping up
these appearances she's horribly like um
repressed in all of these ways and she's
afraid of the rejection that's going to
come out
if she comes out and what's great about
it is that
abby really does try to stick it out and
try to make it work and then eventually
it the truth comes out and it's this
great moment of
of um
[Music]
yeah and harper figures out like i've
screwed up i was wrong
this is bad and i think at the time too
abby's just like too little too late bye
and she leaves
and then harper says
you're right please don't leave i'm
going to i'm going to do better and she
does it's like it's one of the few times
where i think that you know it's clear
that there is a lot of friction and one
one partner is really really wrong but
at the same time she's really wrong in
all these very understandable and very
human ways and so it's more than just
she has a case of the movie stupids you
know what i mean where it's like she's
acting like an idiot in order for the
movie to happen no it's a real reason to
be
to be behaving in this way right yeah
and you're and you're not supposed to
like the way that she's acting and
you're supposed to want more
you are supposed to root for aubry
plaza's character and abby to end up
together for sure i think
i think it's a great little movie i saw
again i saw it last year and i'm really
ready to see it again this year i'm
gonna that's going to be actually i
really tom you're outnumbered on this
one i really liked happiest season um
the only thing is that i'm outnumbered
everybody in the world like this brian i
will argue like i'll argue
i wish not every single like lgbtq love
story was like about
like what something i loved about like
book smart not a christmas movie is that
caitlyn dever's character is out when
the movie begins and there's no kind of
like
fracas about it uh it's not about coming
out you're right and like chief source
of drama not every you know queer
narrative needs to be about that but i
also respect that this one was designed
to be about that and was also created by
queer women and performed by queer women
and so like what it's about yeah it
works it's it it is the thing that it is
and i i just really really like it i
think it's a great movie and if you
haven't checked it out check it out tom
um you don't like it because because you
think that they that they shouldn't be
together right because it's a story
about somebody who lies all the time
like we don't see her do one good thing
through the entire film it's just this
it's one woman like trying desperately
to figure out why she likes this other
woman and you never come up with an
answer by the end it's just like they
are together and therefore they should
love each other so now we know this is
this is not what was released while you
were using all over i guess this is the
thesis of the episode is tom hates liars
i
i'm not fond of liar don't don't don't
step in my territory i'm the one who
lies about things
it ruins relationships i think i
harpooned
my last relationship
by watching happiest season just the
entire
you seem like a perfectly nice young
woman go find another go find a nice
aubrey plaza and marry her have a good
christmas christmas doesn't have to be
like that it could be a nice day this
could be a perfectly nice day i don't
know man
holidays are rough
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]